like only as well it's a real
dichotomous like people being like is it
female empowerment to make money off of
your body or is it disrespectful is it
and I'm very much a middle ground
people like choosing what they want to
choose but I just think we're not honest
with women about the consequences so
like even with body care who cares
because I don't care about the
consequences
and be like people like do you care if
your family I don't give a [ __ ] about my
family it's totally fine like I'm I'm
all for empowered women to do what they
want to do like if you if you want to go
start your own fans go ahead say I'm not
gonna stop you go crazy like get that
bad butt but what I do think we do is
like lie to younger women and tell them
there's no consequences for that stuff
and and so we'll say like oh do sleep
with whoever you want and Men won't care
they shouldn't care but they do care but
uh it depends if you think it's a lie it
really it's really like it's not it's
not it's not if I think it's a lie like
I have these I've 99 male followers I
listen to men talk every day they do
care and biologically there's a reason
they care yeah I mean do they care less
than they did a hundred years ago sure
sure yeah yeah I don't think like most
guys wanted I think most guys don't want
their [ __ ] on only fans yeah but then
we can talk about okay like let's get
real like women can vote women couldn't
have jobs right black people were seen
as literally inhumane right and so you
know if we took that that mindset back
to where we were then black people
weren't human and so you would not be
sat here with us because you would not
be yeah you would yeah I'm just a little
confused what is that like I just what
is it I'm just confused what did that
have to do with what we were talking
about so it's in relation to saying like
we're lying okay so then essentially the
people who went black people are people
they were Liars back then okay
but this is this is what I'm saying it's
lying to women when we're saying like
statistically they're like for example
when you when you sleep with more men
you lose your ability to pair bond so
you have a harder time bonding with your
husband later on like the person that
you marry and there's a million studies
that'll back this up yeah people you
sleep with the less like you you have a
higher probability of being divorced
yeah yeah so so saying to women Empower
yourself and sleep with whoever you I'm
not I'm not saying women should be prude
not everyone wants to get married and
not everyone wants to be power bonded
not everyone and not everyone is scared
of divorced no and that's that's fine
and so but I think we should give women
all of the information oh yeah so yeah
so I'm saying like if you don't want to
be married and you want to be like by
yourself if that's what you want to do
go go do it I'm don't but like don't I
think a lot of times girls follow this
advice and they're not they're not
giving all the information but then
we're also just assuming that every man
is going to be like you're worthless oh
I'm not I'm not assuming every man but I
think the like majority okay majority
would you would you prefer a girl that
has slept with a hundred people or
something with 10. that's it for me 10.
yeah and like I think if you ask like
yeah guys would you prefer someone more
Pure or more more of a hoe most guys are
going to say more pure yeah but then you
see for a relationship yeah but then you
see who and what people then you see who
and what people watch on social media or
porn or who they engage with and you're
like oh you're a hot celebrity or
someone a lot of followers you're
someone who is very desirable or someone
who is and that's it nothing is black
and white the one thing I'll say about
that is I I understand about the whole
desirable thing but guys don't really
care how much
oh God is desired by the men that seems
to be more of a woman thing that they'll
use pre-selected by other women does
that make sense yeah so like you know
you said this example I'll be honest no
matter how many guys are looking and
thirsting over lizzo
I'm not going to be thirsting over her
do you know what I mean she's not what I
would look for whereas like you get
someone like Jonah Hill if he was just
your average guy no one would want him
but because of who he is and women
falling over him a lot of women seem as
attractive because he's desirable to
other women does that make sense yeah
like 100 like I'm that's it I'm
unfortunately I'm I'm aware of the
reality I'm not like delusional
um but then I'm aware of the science but
so being that's it psychology has been
my life for the past like oh my god when
I saw eyesight studying it
oh my God 12 years ago
um and so it's the understanding of why
it's the behavior has come become that
way and the anthropology and all of that
stuff
um so I come from more of a scientific
fact but then I'm like I obviously know
my bias I obviously know XYZ but yeah
like I'm not gonna I'm not delusional in
the lizzo being a big woman is not
attractive but then you know like yeah
it's so so would you agree that we
should give like like the advice if for
a girl that wants to be married would be
to like sleep with as little man as
possible if you want to get married to
the highest value guy you can
um I'm not saying like be a prude I'm
not saying no no no yeah it's like it's
like you should want to marry a man that
wants you regardless but but you don't
think you don't think your choices have
consequences like no I think there's a
consequences right and so you don't
think we should be honest to the Next
Generation saying hey these are the
consequences for those actions if you if
you get on the internet and you you post
your naked body like a guy that that's
worth it
but but do the guys you want care is the
question that's I think that's the
difference I think that the difference
is the the high quality guys that most
other women would want he's more he's
gonna care about these things whereas
there'll be some guys who don't care but
it's likely that those guys that don't
cut are not the guys you want but then
quality again is subjective like would
you rather have someone who just accepts
you for who you are and loves you for
who you are and your history because
then porn stars get married but the
numbers
but here's the thing they need to other
porn stars though but but here's
statistically actually not correct
because I get studies here's the thing
the number numbers the numbers don't lie
and actions have consequences right and
so we could say oh it's subjective like
what is quality but like when you it's
supply and demand yeah like what what
guys and why do we need to all fit into
the majority I'm very happy being
anomaly I'm very happy being oh like and
I and I say and I say go if you want to
be an anomaly go do it if that's what
makes you happy I'm never going to tell
someone how to live their life but what
I'm saying is like why do we lie to
younger women instead of giving them all
the information like why don't we say
the younger woman if you if you want the
highest the guy with the most options
okay if you want the highest quality guy
you can attain
putting your starting and only fans is
not the best way to get there but then
it's like I don't understand like to me
like this is common sense and I feel
like we should agree on this and it's
almost like you like are looking for
that exception because you don't want to
like you don't want to because what
we're doing then is putting what he
wants and he desires and he values above
ourselves well because it's not always
about you and that's that's what I'm
saying like he gets to choose who he
wants to marry and if you want we get to
choose who we want to marry I know Women
Marry who they can no I don't know
that's true like women what they have to
propose so we don't choose we don't have
to remember no not at all
but do you not think do you not think
would you agree that women decide who
have sex
yeah yeah so we do not think that it is
men who decide who gets married
and a woman has the ability to be like
look if you're not going to commit to me
I'm gonna walk away no I know but men
can also say no to sex right but we
understand that culturally when it comes
to having sex it is women who decide to
get access yeah but you women usually
don't say no to marriage either
the majority of women who are proposed
to accept
um and I don't yeah I don't know
statistics that also and again it's
because what I mean is like you know you
know that when you state or from the
first day of a guy you know that he
would have sex with you straight away
so nine times out of ten a guy who's
ready to have sex before the woman
that's why she has the power to who has
sex right
but also nine times out of ten it is the
woman who is ready for the commitment so
he decides who he commits to and I think
that's what Pearl's saying saying that
when it comes to marriage I I think
here's the thing like before any woman
has sex with a guy she has he has to
qualify himself to her before she
accepts that intimacy right
so the same is true that women have to
qualify themselves to men if they want
relationship and commitment
patriarchy why is it the women are the
ones who are like I have to look good I
have to be hairless well why do the man
have to say oh I have to have a good job
I have to like a girl could be
unemployed a dude will still date her
but like men have to qualify themselves
to women too it's like like you're
trying to like take away the things that
men care about yeah and the things that
like the things that women and men care
about just are yeah well that's that's
why I'm very I'm I'm so frustrating and
that I'm very gray area right so that's
it I've had men that are broke men that
are
um objects I'm going to say objectively
not very good looking men that are short
men that actually bring little to the
table other than being nice right and um
so but would you would you prefer a man
that like I would prefer yeah I would
100 prefer a man that brought me more
offered me more but he didn't stop me
from dating other men it didn't stop me
right but then I think I still find the
anomaly in that but I'm saying like you
would still prefer the man that had more
just like the man would still prefer the
woman that had had less guys yeah and I
think like like it just is I'm not
saying I mean I mean it's not like you
know
like double standards just are yeah yeah
I was gonna say as well do you know um
I think the difference is that and this
goes back to like what you were saying
uh what you've all said earlier is I
understand the notion of you know you
said oh but you should want someone who
loves you for you but we all
acknowledged earlier earlier that love
isn't conditioned is not unconditional
like love is very or if we say love at
least who we choose is definitely
conditional and some like you could meet
a guy who you think oh he rocks my world
intimacy wise but if you want to start
having a family and he's really not
doing anything with his life it's like
you may really care about him but you
may not choose him over the next guy who
can do that for you does that make sense
yeah and then I think it also depends
upon like I'm gonna be real it's really
depends upon your mental health your
well-being you're like so I settled for
people who treat me like [ __ ] and if if
someone from outside when Amy this is
what this guy is doing to me I'd be like
are you confused like leave him like
what the [ __ ]
um and yeah like I fully like agree with
that I fully agree that like that's it's
just not a simple yes or no but would
you would you would you then go back
because love is conditional would you go
back on your statement that like the man
shouldn't love you for you like it's
it's conditional based on the choices
yeah like that's it so yeah that makes
sense so so you would agree then to to
younger women we should tell you um that
actions have consequences and going on
only fans might not be the best action
if you want a husband I think well
that's the reality is that yeah it will
have consequences yeah because it will
some men won't care some men will care
right you have to be okay and you have
to be responsible to be like I know that
if I'm on only fans some men are gonna
be like you're trash okay with that as
many of you know I was just banned on
Tick Tock and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform if you want
to help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible